[music]
>> So, I'm You. I'm from Gelbort.
We are a
leading generalist robot company from
China. And Gelbort, it means
galaxy robot. Actually, it means the
vision of our founder that we want to
make a robot that has the
generalizability in the whole galaxy, in
the whole universe.
So, today I'm going to share with you
how to we build a generalist robot and
not only in the technology side, but
also have been successfully deploy it
into multiple scenarios.
Okay. So, this slide shows architecture
what we are doing. So, basically in the
core size, we have released a foundation
model, a single foundation model that
combines the cerebrum and cerebellum and
also the whole body, whole hand control
system into one single foundation model.
We call it Astro brain.
And it is driven by the largest embodied
AI data sets. We call Astro data. And
the reason why we have been able to
drive the successful foundation model is
because everybody know that the crucial
part for embodied AI is the data. So,
over the past few years, our company, we
have been striving and also create the
very unique paradigm. We leverage
different kind of data to, you know,
finally to embed and train into this
foundation model. And also on the
device-wise, we focus a lot on the
wheelbase because uh
we believe that truly in the working
capability, providing the value into the
like manufacturing in the
retailing is the key here into the usage
of the robot.
But we also have the bipedal version of
robot, but we still focus more on the
wheel base. And now in the past years,
we have deployed thousands of
our robots in
several key scenarios including
manufacturing, including retailing,
including logistics and warehouse, and
also health care.
So Keble is
just in one word, we are one of the very
few company have the full stack
technology. Just compare our company to
a like a vehicle company, we see the
robot as a device as a device and the
foundation model as an engine. The most
difficult part is the data like I
mentioned. It's also the energy part. So
like I mentioned, we have accumulate 20
billion of embodied AI data, which is by
far the largest in this world. The
reason why it's so difficult is because
we know that for
a large language model, we can get free
amount of like text, picture or video
online. But for embodied AI, we actually
need a 3D space data.
We need a trajectory data for the
the robot arm to interact with different
items. And this kind of data can be
extremely
expensive and also very hard to get. And
we release a very special paradigm of
sim to real.
So
besides the real scenario data, besides
the human behavior data, we also have a
very special synthetic data to drive the
flywheel of the embodied AI data set to
to run.
And this is from the this year's GTC.
The left-hand side actually shows
a video that was
shown in the keynote speech by Mr.
Jensen Huang. And Nvidia actually
developed based on our platform to
develop a very interesting use case in
the pharmaceutical area and they develop
in in their is the same first in the
simulator first and then deploy it on
our robot platform and show the live
demo at GTC. So this is a very good
example that besides the general skills
we develop and we train on our robot
platform we also open our platform and
global SDK to the
globally and for especially for the
vertical use case.
And a little bit recap for the road map
of the artificial intelligence. Remember
how we come here to today.
So first of all we see the AlphaGo
moment when artificial intelligence can
play the chess
towards human being and then comes the
GPT-2 moment actually propose a
universal solution to all language tasks
and scale up it and then the GPT chat
GPT moment that accomplish all language
and finally make it like a human being
can do like a reasoning and talking
similar to a human being level. And now
it becomes a more faster usage in our
daily life.
So when we look into the embodied AI's
road map we see the similar road map.
We also see like a a more vertical use
case.
Just like a AlphaGo moment and then we
are actually heading for a scaling up of
the data in embodied AI which drive to
the GPT-2 moment. And future we are also
looking forward to a robot that can have
the reasoning and working capability
similar to a human being level.
That's what we call the GPT chat GPT
moment for embodied AI.
So this is what we call a AlphaGo moment
for humanoids.
This is the world's first humanoid that
can place tennis ball rally towards a
human being. This is a work that we
released this March. And the technology
is already updated after that. But it's
still under confidential development.
So, I'm I'm showing you here actually
the initial version. So, on this video
you can see the work is 100% autonomous.
The humanoid driven by our foundation
model can play the tennis ball rally at
least eight to 10 round of rally towards
a human being. It need to think well. It
need to see where the tennis ball is
coming. Well, it's It need to think how
it can run to the right direction and
fight back the tennis ball.
And also, you probably know anyone play
tennis ball, you also know that if you
don't catch the tennis ball in the sweet
spot in the pad, you are going to not
fight back back good enough, right? So,
this are all reasoned by the humanoid by
our foundation model in real time. This
combines a low level of
whole body control and also high level
of reasoning. So, this is a very good
example shows our work in a single
foundation model combine the cerebrum
and also cerebellum together.
And this work has been become a viral on
the internet. Even Elon Musk and
Andrew Khang and
Andrej Karpathy claimed that this is
insane. This must be made by AI. But the
reality is that actually we are showing
it on site later this year.
And we want to make sure that everything
is fully upgraded until we show it.
Okay, a little bit more on how we do it.
So, basically this work are being trend
based on the motion capture data on
human being.
On human being, how human being play the
tennis ball. So, we trend that, we put
this later into our simulator, and then
our humanoid try to learn it basically
from two parts. One is the basic skill,
how does human being play the tennis
ball? Like what kind of movement, what
kind of tactic to play the tennis ball?
And the other thing is that we run the
data to trend the humanoid to know how
to move this naturally, lively. So, what
we see is from the the video just
what I show is that the humanoid not
only learn how to play the tennis ball
back bucket, also the whole movement is
natural like a human being.
And another work we have been doing on
the
actually on the cerebrum is that we
released this world first the dexterous
hand neurodynamic model.
Before that, we all know that dexterous
hand is most difficult work because
there is no way to teleoperate it.
So, it's called the pearl on the crown
of humanoid.
And driven by our foundation model, even
open source hand like leap can handle
different shape, like complicated item,
and freely, and rotate it on the hand in
different direction.
And it can also handle different tools
on different items.
So, you probably know that some
dexterous hand can do some precision
work, but
as far as we know, all of the
traditional way is based on the
pre-written trajectory. So, that means
that if the hand can use a screwdriver,
if we change you another screwdriver,
the original way, the traditional will
not work.
So, the generalizability in dexterous is
extremely hard. And we have proved that
with our algorithm that dexterous can
handle different kind of item. And in
this in this year's Spring Festival, in
this year
February,
we use the dexterous hand to swing two
chestnuts in hand.
The center of the gravity of the two
chestnuts are constantly changing.
There's no way to teleoperate it. And
our
the dexterous hand driven by our
algorithm can rotate it and adapt the
different the gravity the center and
rotate it freely.
So, this is our architecture. So,
basically, you see that we are using the
multimodal signal and global states and
instructions to, you know, uh
basically, run like a architecture like
a human being's brain.
So, input it into the cerebellum and
also to the cerebrum and connected with
the pons.
So, this whole architecture we learn
from human's brain. We borrow this idea
into our foundation model.
And this is another work that we
released in this uh actually in this
May, very recently. This is what we call
a foundation model for the whole body
control.
And we compared it with the NVIDIA Sonic
like from the
uh latency and smooth level, you can see
that apparently that our work has been
achieving a higher performance. So, this
is also because this work have actually
leveraged the biggest human uh behavior
data. We used 2 billion frames of human
behavior data to train our model. And
also,
uh one more thing here, we didn't show
it on this video. Actually, previously,
for the humanoid to perform this kind of
work, it needs to, you know, two things.
One is that in the pre-trained data set,
it needs to have this kind of movement
before. And actually, in our model, we
prove that we don't need to have the
exact behavior trend. We can actually
have the
new behavior performed with zero shot.
It proves the generalizability. And the
second, the based on the original whole
body control algorithm, we will have the
limit or constraint on those movement
that is hard for the humanoid to
retain balance. So, for example, for a
very hard movement like bouncing to the
ground,
the humanoid would do the It would be
limited to, you know, reflect the exact
movement, but we compare that
with the Mediasound We can do a more
like extreme movement. Even the
humanoid sense that it's going to be
forced through ground, it can still
remain balanced.
And this is another work. This is our
latest work on where action model.
So, previously, we know that VOA model
is more prevail in this
like foundation model in in body AI.
And we also release our VOA model like 2
years ago. Also, proves to have the
highest
success rate, 98% of success rate. And
we actually combine the advantage and
our experience in VOA model into the
the advantage of forecast of where
model, and we release the world first
where action model last March. And this
year, we upgraded
to a like more long horizon and
multi-task ability, and we call it the
Astro brain where action model 0.5.
And driven that by this model, you can
see that
uh our robots can handle long horizon
work like cooking in the kitchen,
handling steak, and even like add some
flavor to the steak.
And recently, we are we show a video on
the website that our robot can cook the
breakfast and pouring some juice to the
glass. Even the people are try to, you
know, interrupt with the movement, and
it can all close loop the task.
And this work can also
work on different robot device. We have
proved the cross embodiment not only on
our long arm global G1, also on the
short arm version, and also on the
Unitree G1.
And this is also a work that has
leveraged a very small and light
database. Actually, we only have a 1.6
billion parameter. So, that means that
it can be easily deployed on the edge
side edge computing. And
going forward, we are going to enlarge
the data. So, that's what we say that
when we find a way to scale up the data,
there will be a better approach to reach
the chat GPT moment in embodied AI. And
for word action model, we actually also
have proved another significant break
break through in this area. So,
previously in VLA, we leverage expert
behavior, which is a high-quality data.
In this work, we leverage even
low-quality data,
unlabeled data. So, we leverage all of
them. For high-quality data, we use the
data to do the
the policy manipulation and in war and
forward and also video jam. And for
those unlabeled data, we use it to
forecast for the video jam. So, we have
proved we are able to use the
different structure, different quality
of data to the best extent.
And this is also a very good important
finding that if we are able to use the
low quality data, we open the gate for
the future for embodied AI to large
leverage a vast amount of data because
the the way the barrier to find the data
for embodied AI is lowered.
So, this is also a very important
insight that we are approaching the chat
GPT moment of embodied AI.
So, this is a data hybrid. We use the
vast amount of information like internet
data, like human behavior data from the
internet, and also the human motion
capture data. And we also have synthetic
data. That is the unique technology from
our company. We have closed the gap
between the seam and the real world. And
we also have the real world teleoperated
data. We have built a teleoperated
training farm, data farm in multiple
cities, and that is the high quality
data that we mentioned. And also, we
deployed over thousands of robots
already in real world, and this data
kept on feedback and fine-tuning our
foundation model.
And this is a short list of the partners
we have found the cooperation. So, we
have found the cooperation with the
leading manufacturers including Bosch
Group, including Siemens, and including
CATL, the leading battery maker, and
also Mercedes-Benz, Hyundai Motors, and
the leading vehicle makers in China.
And this is a a very interesting video
that
from the Fox News. Their broadcaster
Brett visited
our company when he's accompanying the
uh, visit of a Donald Trump to Beijing
and he literally enter this convenience
store, Family Mart. It's a real
convenience store and he see a robot
working there. That is our robot. And
there's no voice of this video.
Actually, Brad was talking to the robot,
"Hey, can I order a sausage, please?"
And you see our robot answer him, "Okay,
kaoucha 8.8 yuan." In Chinese, very
funny. And then the robot going to, you
know, to the
oven and handle a sausage to Brad
immediately. Brad got so surprised. Wow.
This are done in 1 minute and the robot
can even understand and finish the task
just by language communication.
You see?
Okay. So, another thing here. So, we
talked more about the foundation model,
about the AI technology, but for a
humanoid to work in real scenario, it
needs also to be sustainable on the
hardware-wise. And our team, although we
are very young company, our team has
been working together for over a decade.
And this is show the smart pharmacy.
Actually, we have built over 100 smart
pharmacy in China over 33 cities and the
first one was opened at the end of 2024.
And that robot working in that smart
pharmacy has non-stop continuously work
7 days, 24 hours for 18 months.
So, this has already proved the
sustainability of our work, of our
robot. So, given the time limit, I will
just the very quickly
flip the This is a Gable store. We have
opened 170 Gable store. Please come to
China, enjoy it. That is the convenience
store operated purely by humanoid and we
have opened the
40 cities already.
And this is another Yeah.
Another product, very important, Gelper
S1. This is also the world's first
humanoid with a payload of over 50 kg.
And this robot has been deployed in
Siemens factory.
Also in CATL factory. They have a really
strict bar for safety because they are
making battery, which is very expensive
and also can be dangerous to drop into
the ground. So they require 100% success
rate.
And we are the only robot that working
at CATL factory autonomously. And this
is a massive deployed in Great Wall
Motors with our Gelper G1.
And this is with a Mercedes-Benz in
their Beijing Shunyi factory.
And this is for Hyundai Motors for the
spare parts sorting.
So given the time limit, I'll just uh
very quickly flip to the end. So there
is a contact on this page. If you are
interested in our robots, please contact
with me. Yeah. Thank you for for your
time and thank you for